hey this is pressure Walker how sharp
are your calculus skills the formula for
integration by parts states that the
integral of U DV is equal to UV minus
the integral of VDU let's use the
formula to evaluate the integral of 1
over X DX
we'll set u to be 1 over X and DV to be
DX D u will equal negative 1 over x
squared DX and V will be equal to X we
now use the integration by parts formula
we need u times V this will be 1 over x
times X we then need to subtract out the
D u this will be the following integral
we now need to simplify this equation 1
over x times X will be equal to 1 and
the next integral will all simplifies to
be the integral of 1 over X DX and this
is all equal to the integral of 1 over X
DX we now have the integral of 1 over X
DX on both sides so we cancel it out and
we end up that the left hand side will
be equal to 0 and the right hand side
will be equal to 1 so we proved that 0
is equal to 1 now of course this is an
absurd conclusion so the question is
where is the mistake in this supposed
proof that 0 is equal to 1 take a moment
to review this proof carefully when
you're ready keep watching the video for
an explanation of where the mistake is
so the mistake in the proof is
cancelling the indefinite integrals and
forgetting about the constant of
integration up to this line in the proof
is correct the problem is when we take
these two indefinite integrals and
cancel them out you can't cancel them
out because the
only unique up to a constant of
integration to put it another way let's
suppose that the antiderivative of 1
over X is equal to some function capital
f of X when we evaluate the indefinite
integral on the left hand side it'll be
capital f of X plus a lowercase C some
constant of integration when we evaluate
this indefinite integral on the right
hand side it will be the same function
but it may be a different constant of
integration which I'll denote by a
capital C so we can cancel out these
anti derivatives but then we end up with
the equation that lowercase C is equal
to 1 plus uppercase C so we haven't
proven that 0 is equal to 1 we've
actually proven that the content of
integrations will differ by 1 in other
words 0 is equal to 1 up to a constant
of integration so that's the mistake in
the proof is cancelling out these in
depth and integrals so one way to avoid
this mistake is you consider limits of
integration so if you had the integral
from A to B of 1 over X DX we then use
the integration by parts formula to get
the integral of 1 from A to B plus the
integral of 1 over X DX from A to B now
what happens when we evaluate the
function 1 from A to B well this will be
equal to 1 at both points and we're
going to subtract that so we get 1 minus
1 and of course 1 minus 1 is equal to 0
so when we simplify this we get the
definite integral from A to B of 1 over
X DX will be equal to the definite
integral of 1 over X DX from A to B so
we have no contradiction here and it's
also not very interesting you can avoid
the mistake of cancelling indefinite
integrals and getting absurd results
like 0 equal 1 by considering limits of
integration this video is also a
reminder that it's a very very important
when you do indefinite integrals or take
anti derivatives to always include that
plus C students always complain
that oh I didn't put the plus C there
but I got the correct answer
no you really need to put that plus C
otherwise you can get absurd results
like zero equals one so how sharp were
your skills did you spot the mistake in
this false proof thanks for watching
this video please subscribe to my
channel I make videos on math you can
catch me on my blogs mind your decisions
that you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch you on social
media at pressure Locker and if you
liked this video please check out my
books there are links in the video
description